labour's plan to tackle the cost of
living crisis is to freeze the energy
price cap with immediate effect keeping
it at its current level of just under 2
000 pounds through winter that's the
biggest dark blue bar on this chart the
red bars afterwards show the latest
forecasts of where it'll shoot up to as
things stand to more than 4 200 pounds
in january by keeping the price cap
where it is labor claims it would save
the average household 1 000 pounds but
how would they pay for it first an
extension of the windfall tax on oil and
gas companies profits now that's already
expected to raise five billion pounds
this year but labor thinks it can get
that to eight billion by backdating it
to january and it wants to ditch the tax
relief currently offered on new
investments that second chunk of 14
billion pounds would come from scrapping
the 400 pound energy rebate that's been
promised to every household in october
and third labor projects 7 billion would
come from lower interest payments on
government debt which it says would be
reduced because lower energy bills would
bring down inflation now labor claims
cpi consumer prices index would peak at
nine percent which is where it is now
rather than the 13
the bank of england forecasts but
experts say that's not guaranteed and
what's more labor's plan only runs until
april so what happens then if bills go
up inflation would too
this would clearly do a lot to reduce uh
energy bills for households of course
leaving people with more money in their
pockets to spend on other things would
add to inflationary pressures elsewhere
in the economy
you also have to ask what's going to
happen after next april um when at the
moment energy prices aren't forecast to
come down so there would presumably be a
lot of pressure to carry on something
like this beyond next april
so how does this compare to the tory
leadership hopefuls well we already know
that liz trust and rishi sunak are
unlikely to extend the windfall tax or
freeze the price cap and both would keep
that 400 pound energy rebate front
runner liz druss also wants to remove
green and social levies from energy
bills currently worth just over 150
pounds a year she'd also reverse the
recent national insurance hike as for
rishi sunak he would scrap the 5
vat on energy bills saving households
around 200 pounds next year and he's
also promised to give the most
vulnerable hundreds of pounds more or
exactly how much though he hasn't said
none of the proposals though tackle the
fundamental problems of demand and
supply capping bills would help
households in the short term but it
wouldn't cut their consumption and if
the windfall tax is extended energy
companies may well think twice about
future investment